somehow newsom is not even the worst
governor in the country right now the
worst governor in the country a man we
should certainly cancel
andrew cuomo you know andrew cuomo
has gotten credit for being the greatest
governor on covid even though his state
leads in
or is at least very near to the top in
total death count
death rate just an absolute failure in
the handling of coronavirus
and this guy had the unmitigated goal to
write a book about leadership lessons
from kovit it probably has the same
content as my
first magnum opus reasons to vote for
democrats totally blank book
so we've been saying for months and
months i spoke to my friend who's a new
york state assemblyman kevin burn the
other day
we've been saying that cuomo is directly
responsible in his policies for
a lot of extra deaths particularly among
senior citizens particularly in new
york's nursing homes
the media won't cover this sort of thing
but now it turns out we're right andrew
cuomo's top aide
her name is secretary to the governor
melissa derosa
she just admitted and apologized in a
phone call
to democratic lawmakers for the cover-up
in new york nursing home deaths during
the covet epidemic
a cover-up i used that word very
specifically this woman
says that the cuomo administration quote
froze out of the fear that the
nursing home deaths quote the numbers
would be against us
by federal prosecutors and therefore
they wanted to hide the numbers from the
feds so there wasn't an investigation
thousands and thousands and thousands of
new york senior citizens died
needlessly because of the cuomo
administration's policies
they knew this at the time when they
realized it they hid the numbers
not just from you and me and the public
but from federal investigators and
prosecutors
because they knew how bad this looked
she says
we apologize we do apologize i do
understand the position that you were
put in
i know that it is not fair
now i'm hoping listening to this that
she's apologizing to the families
of these dead senior citizens right it
was not fair we put you in this terrible
position i'm so sorry
no that's not who she's apologizing to
she goes on
it was not our intention to put you in
that political position
with the republicans the woman is not
apologizing
cuomo administration is not apologizing
to the families of these dead senior
citizens she's not apologizing to the
senior citizens themselves
she's apologizing to democrats because
there are reckless policies that killed
thousands of seniors
and the cover-up that followed put
democrats in a bad political position
that's the kind of administration we're
talking about this man andrew cuomo
the worst governor in the country a
truly corrupt politician
i've i've had the uh privilege or
displeasure of
of meeting andrew cuomo a couple times
because i actually we're from
right around the same town in new york
and uh i've
run into him in other places a real
bulldog type of a guy a
pure political animal he's been in it
since his dad was governor it was clear
to anybody with two eyes
what was going on during kovid but the
mainstream media refused to report on it
take a listen to their
as andrew cuomo's policies were killing
all these seniors and as he was covering
it up from the feds
this is how the media covered him david
we're standing by for governor cuomo's
press conference his daily briefing
how would you contrast cuomo and
president trump's handling of the crisis
truth versus mendacity governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't
honest direct brave real leadership of
the kind the president of the united
states
should have provided governor cuomo is
clearly living in a totally different
reality
the actual one than the president of the
united states governor cuomo has become
a national leader
for a lot of people andrew cuomo has
become the leader of the democratic
party
he is conveying incredible strength you
spoke
to national guard troops today in a
stirring speech that
if i wasn't listening carefully i
thought you would sending soldiers off
to war
this has been a remarkable show of
leadership by governor cuomo in recent
days
he's providing hope but not false hope
governor
cuomo i think is is one of the heroes on
the front lines
with all of this adulation that you're
getting for doing your job
are you thinking about running for
president are you you should be you're
doing such a good
job andrew cuomo you're doing such a
wonderful job says
his brother chris cuomo how corrupt is
this whole edifice
all the while they were pushing this
propaganda
this dude cuomo was through his policies
killing senior citizens
and through his other policies covering
it up
remember that next time you trust the
media if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button so everyone
waiting through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]